welcome to this video playing professor
Smith it's a really high rating no name
it's got the GM title that's always good
oops so news away f I'm trying for my
dice is same issue yeah which at least
gives interesting games in almost all
cases let's see what he's going to play
surprised that that good players go for
that and this one really okay I don't
think that this is any good I have to
have to be perfectly honest them
okay so it's going to add grab this and
now the ads both interesting pawn takes
is also interesting I habit night cheeks
and I TIG seems right for one takes H
for the screen age five mmm tweenage
five and what does see what are you
doing Quincy five maybe okay you can try
to play that end game Queen g5 ruku cage
for and then play that end game yeah
maybe hmm anything better Queen d2 also
Queen g5 so I have to do this problem
Queen g5s Tony move and now look h4 take
too long here I have to play those moves
probably in any case yeah night cheeks
is this making some sense not sure and
now how do i quickly get the other look
on the edge file with f3 f3 King f2
group h 1 ok he will always go gauge 8mm
King moves don't cut it wrong castles
doesn't make any sense so maybe f3
ok always has to cover the h6 pawn
somehow try it for 93 and then maybe g
three and four currently is not easily
getting at my pawns at least i don't see
it 86 be five maybe
try and form Bishop g4 if i can get
those traded hmm i get them traded let's
it's a nice it looks nice ok five I
should have thought for a moment there
King a three first was stronger much
stronger ah
aah ja shoot I could have could have had
an even better position and this isn't
this is not bad but it could have been
check much much better
and for the shame that was that that
game was there for the taking really was
just King f3 and he's got a totally
totally bad position I think that was
really close to unplayable for black
check
where takes age 6 is that not working
why not don't see it chime warning check
check check now an idea for yeah yeah
okay okay white resign oh that's 96
check maybe I didn't even need to resign
I probably lose on time but I have 96 I
only see it now I'm actually better
still yeah but this is this is just this
is just so bad if I go he come he got
completely outplayed in this game and I
just have to play King King up here and
this is over rly he's not keeping that
f6 pawn what what's the engine giving
1.5 on d oh that's I expected more him
thought like plus two or so is this just
lost him he loses f6 which is which is
just losing position and it's totally
passive I can also go here ah more below
to check such a good scalp yeah am
amazed that people play this this is not
a good setup I don't believe it don't
believe it really tween age 5 yeah what
a shame that was a very nice game the
computer finding anything better let's
just check it
not really yeah okay and here gets messy
just get messy I mean again white is
also much better here after G takes it
seems but this is just not I was just
adjust this end and that's it his night
is dead compare it to this night this
can be stopped easily this is just
terribly bad I can I mean I'm not quite
sure even how you do that this is also
pretty strong then here and so on just
very very bad yeah probably there were
still chances here but check I just was
supposed to to irritated and check 96
just wins outright okay rupee six check
not quite sure why I cannot go to the
seven wow how many chances do I wanted
have been again yeah I wish I was
probably just 22 NJ at not playing the
king and didn't take my my chances that
properly I'm still better King g3 is a
big advantage and so on okay now and
again I can't continue him yeah I was
very stupid and he actually has to check
on his success the night is hanging I
was there especially very bad
psychologically I just have to continue
him it's not even difficult to play
the computer gives us as the best line
check ending in the drawer yeah I really
should have taken one of those gifts at
least he handed out a couple losing it
is a really a pretty pretty bad result
from that game okay thanks for watching